[Music]
bringing a baby into the world
it all begins with the birds and the
bees
except when it doesn't
fertility innovation has come a long way
since the introduction of in vitro
fertilization now things like artificial
intelligence and cutting-edge techniques
are helping make the dream of a family
become a reality
okay
when this couple in Maple Ridge British
Columbia began thinking of having a
child they knew they had some big
biological hurdles to overcome the
cheapest thing possible Stephen was a
widower with two grown children Erica
had no children of her own how long's it
been since when the pandemic hit they
started prioritizing what was important
to them
I realized that it was something I still
really wanted wanted to see if Steve
would be open to that and it was a lot
of conversations
um yeah yeah it took a long time yeah
yeah we went to see a counselor to talk
things through and and through that
really was was helpful in a lot of ways
it was hard it was really hard on our
relationship that's why I asked you
about like meds my main concern is that
I'm 60 now and I need to stay healthy
thank you so much that's excellent and
Erica in her 40s knew she wasn't the
ideal candidate for pregnancy I'm older
my eggs are older
um so there was that that played into it
too this wasn't a guarantee after
deciding they were ready to go for it hi
there Erica and Steven met with Dr Sonia
kashup director of Genesis fertility in
Vancouver a leading West Coast Clinic
that helps people conceive the natural
pregnancy rates at age 40 are about six
percent per month compared to at age 30
which are about 20 per month to improve
Erica's odds she was given medication to
stimulate her ovaries I took the
injections for 10 days to try and get as
many eggs as we could and we were hoping
for 10 but there was only four Stephen
also needed some help Steve had a
vasectomy 20 years ago so if we were
going to do this it would have to be
very purposeful sperm doesn't really age
not fair at all
so in order to use his sperm you have to
go through a procedure to extract the
sperm if you can't
vasectomy reversal which usually after
about seven years you can't
to retrieve Steven's sperm they sought
the help of Dr Ryan Flanagan he's an
assistant professor at the University of
British Columbia and founder of the
Flanagan fertility clinic in Vancouver
so what specifically does your clinic do
my subspecialty is in infertility and
sexual medicine so I'll see couples with
all forms of infertility and I treat the
male side of things Stephen had healthy
detectable sperm but because of his
vasectomy Dr Flanagan had to use a
process called PESA or percutaneous
epididymal sperm aspiration to retrieve
it did you two even know that all these
things were possible before you started
your journey because of this it was an
extraction and not just a regular sample
of sperm they actually injected the the
egg with the sperm right so they find a
sperm that looks the best and they
actually inject it right into the egg so
it's a bit of a different procedure than
right than just the regular IVF so we
didn't know that that was possible
the fertility Tech boom started in 1978
with in vitro fertilization the eggs are
sucked out through a needle inserted in
the abdomen where egg and sperm are
united outside of the womb then
implanted in the uterus science has
taken off in the decades since with the
ability to freeze eggs retrieve sperm
and detect healthy embryos but there's
always room for more Innovation so what
are the biggest challenges that your
patients face is it things like low
sperm count yeah low sperm count can
often be some of the most challenging
things to overcome and when there is no
detectable sperm what do you do when we
don't see any sperm most often it's a
failure to produce sperm within the
testicle
when we're in this scenario the most
common direction of treatment if we're
trying to get that individual sperm is
to do a microsurgical procedure called
microtesce where essentially we're
looking inside the testicle using a
microscope to try try to find rare areas
of sperm production that could then be
used with IVF micro tesi differs from
pessa the procedure Stephen had because
it involves taking a tissue sample that
a clinician then searches through for
active sperm when we do these biopsies
during the micro testing procedure we
may be collecting tens of millions of
cells and we're asking them to find tens
to hundreds of sperm in order to
facilitate an IVF around it's like
looking for a needle in a haystack on a
microscopic level they will literally
search for hours under a microscope or
they're trying to use their eye to
distinguish amongst hundreds of cells in
a field to try to find this single sperm
sometimes where they may not find a
sperm for hundreds of thousands of
fields when they're searching through
how often do they find the viable sperm
in a case like this it's about 50
percent of the time
Dr Flanagan believes there's a better
way using AI so we have been working on
trying to create a technology where
we're using artificial intelligence to
train an algorithm to identify a sperm
uh amongst all these millions of other
types of cells so how much would this
change things for couples wanting to
conceive we're hoping that a greater
percentage than the current 50 percent
of couples would be able to have sperm
identified
Toronto fertility specialist Dr Dan
nayotte is also using AI to increase the
odds of conception but his focus is on
eggs as it stands now the human eye is
not capable of confirming the quality of
an egg although we've tried to visually
score eggs for decades now there hasn't
been a validated evaluation system We
Believe machine learning could unlock
this Mystery by feeding a computer
program thousands of pictures of eggs
and correlating them to successful
pregnancies he believes they can more
accurately predict which eggs will
become the best candidates for making
babies we've had a lot of interest from
around the world we're already in
several clinics in North America in
Europe it is a counseling tool what
we're doing with our AI is personalizing
that feedback and is to say yes you're
36 years old and you have 10 eggs but
when we've analyzed each egg this is our
personal prediction of what we think
your chances of success are that's
really important information because
perhaps she should do another cycle or a
third cycle to get more eggs because
when she comes back in the future and if
it does not work she may not have this
opportunity again this is your over on
the right side
but wasn't an option Erica explored well
now I'll be laying on their own they're
[Music]
our age and the cost of the fertility
treatment she was already undergoing she
was only prepared to give it one shot
and we feel very lucky that we were able
to pay for it once a lot of people are
not able to pay for it at all yeah so we
feel fortunate and in that respect but
it is very expensive very expensive may
ask how much it is oh yeah yeah I think
it was 25. about 25 000. yeah oh wow so
yeah I actually paid for someone to put
needles in the testicles just to draw it
out some spam yeah so we were like we're
just gonna do this once if this doesn't
work I'm gonna have to be okay with with
not having kids and I I've resigned to
that three embryos were implanted in
Erica's uterus essentially putting all
the couple's eggs in one basket yeah
it's normal and ten days later a
positive pregnancy test one of many I
took so many pregnancy tests like every
day yeah I kept taking them because I
just I I did believe it but it just
seems so surreal you know and for
something that I didn't think that I was
going to have it was just like I I
wanted to hold on to that excitement
nine months later Elliot arrived oh dear
[Music]
[Music]
will you tell him the story of how he
came to be when he gets older absolutely
yeah
maybe it was something that was a stigma
you know way back when but I think these
days it's just becoming more and more
the norm are you watching Rosie
Genesis gives you a picture of the
embryos when right before they put them
in so when they're you know three days
old and right before they they put them
back in my uterus you know these this
little clump of cells and so I have this
picture of these three embryos and one
of those is him and that's how cool is
that to be able to show him and say like
that was you like that's that's the
earliest baby picture you can possibly
have yeah and most of us don't get that
no no most of it is in the hospital or
maybe an ultrasound I think he'll like
the story I think it's a really cool
story